el ex atleta paralímpico Oscar pistorios
tendrá que permanecer al menos un año y
cuatro meses más en prisión luego de que
la junta de libertad condicional que
analizó su caso le negara el beneficio
de Libertad bajo palabra la junta
Consideró que todavía es visto no ha
cumplido la mitad de la pena impuesta
por el homicidio de su novia la modelo
riva stingham el corredor sudafricano y
su historia en Londres en 2012 al ser el
primer paralímpico que corría contra
atletas convencionales pero 7 meses
después fue detenido por el asesinato de
su pareja el atleta fue sentenciado a 13
años en 2016 para analizar este caso
está con nosotros una de nuestras
cronistas deportivas Omar esa Gracias
por estar con nosotros Omar estamos
hablando de la historia de un héroe que
cayó en desgracia si un héroe que pasó
De héroe Villano en apenas seis meses
pistores recordemos fue el primer gran
Astro del deporte paralímpico
básicamente por su lucha para competir
contra atletas convencionales que
incluso lo llevó a enfrentarse a la
antiguaya Félix en el tribunal de
arbitraje del deporte
intentó participar en Beijing 2008 pero
la antigua iaf lo declaró no elegible
con base en un estudio científico que
decía que su prótesis de fibra de
carbono le daban ventaja Porque después
de la salida corría de forma más
eficiente que un atleta convencional lo
que implicaba menor desgaste para
alcanzar la velocidad máxima pistorios
recorrió ante el Tas basado en un
informe de un experto en biomecánica
también doblo amputado un antiguo
montañista que mostraba que tanto su
consumo energético como su Rango de
fatiga eran iguales a los de los atletas
convencionales eso revirtió la decisión
de la iaf y le permitió participar en
Londres 2012 a donde clasificó con una
marca de 45 07 para que se dé una idea
el récord Nacional de mi país de
Venezuela es 45 21 de manera que corrió
más rápido que eso que un atleta
convencional un atleta que fue
considerado como ejemplo que súbitamente
mostró su cara más oscura de aficionado
a las armas y de obsesionado con los
temas de seguridad el mar estamos
hablando de un caso en el que ha habido
una enorme presión Por parte sobre todo
de la familia de arriba es incap para
que episodios no goce de este beneficio
y cumpla toda su condena en prisión si
recordemos que la decisión inicial en
2014 fue declararlo culpable de
homicidio culposo condenarlo a cinco
años de prisión y luego Esto fue
conmutado por arresto domiciliario en
2015 la corte de apelaciones cambia la
calificación del delito con el argumento
de que pistorius tenía intenciones de
matar fuera a su novia o a un intruso
que era lo que él argumentaba la versión
que sostuvo siempre se rejuga Entonces
por asesinatos se le condena a seis años
pero la fiscalía por supuesto a
instancias de la familia de Rivas tinka
recurre y en 2017 la Corte Suprema dobla
la pena a 13 años en junio del año
pasado pistorius participó junto al
padre de arriba en una audiencia
conocida como diálogo víctima agresor
que es parte del sistema sudafricano de
justicia a la que tiene derecho para
poder solicitar la Libertad bajo palabra
lo hizo pero ahora a pesar de que
cumplió con ese requisito Ahora tiene
que esperar hasta agosto de 2024 para
poder aspirar de nuevo al beneficio la
familia de episodios la familia que
asegura que no ha habido remordimiento
por parte de episturíos Omar como
siempre Muchísimas gracias